Hello, welcome to View from the Danube.
I'm your host, Rod Dreer. We're joined
today by Raymond Ibrahim, who is a
visiting fellow at the Danube Institute
and the author of The Sword and the
Scimitar. And as usual, Callum
Nicholson, also here at the Danube
Institute, and Philip Pilkington, a
macroeconomist who is also a visiting
fellow of the Danube Institute and
probably the most uh energetic
guy on X about the Iran war. We're going
to talk about the Iran war today,
Philip. Now, I should say to our
listeners and viewers that the war is
obviously an extremely fluid situation.
So the picture we're going to give them
today may not be the picture next week
or it might be. What's your take on
what's happened?
>> Well, I suppose we should start with
where it started, right? I mean, the the
the plan as far as anyone can tell on
the part of the Trump administration was
some sort of a decapitation strike of
the leadership, probably the Ayatollah,
who was killed, of course, and senior
IRGC command, that's Iranian
Revolutionary Guard Corps, who kind of
run the country behind the scenes in a
lot of ways. And you know some of the
initial strikes I guess were a success
on their face. The Ayatollah Kamini is
was killed but the regime hasn't
collapsed. I mean that's very clear. So
what is happening now is it's
transitioning into a into a form of
attrition warfare actually. But the
attrition warfare isn't like what we see
in Ukraine or have seen in Ukraine since
2022 which is attrition ground warfare.
A lot of drones, artillery fire and so
on. It's a form of um u missile
attrition warfare. So it's all standoff
munitions very far away from each other.
The United States and Israel, I should
say, are mainly using um planes. And
then the Iranians are responding with
very heavy um short-range and
intermediate range uh ballistic
missiles, which we're seeing rain down
all over the Gulf. I mean, Israel's
getting hit, got hit in the 12-day war,
it's getting hit again. But
>> well, that's what's changed. So the in
the 12-day war, everything was focused
on Israel. Currently the Gulf States are
being hit and specifically the American
bases in the Gulf States are being hit.
They're not the only thing being hit.
Dubai is being hit very heavily.
Airports are being hit. Energy
infrastructure, we can talk about that
in a bit.
>> Um so what you have is the beginnings of
a form of attrition war but using
missiles. But if you just read Pentagon
and American think tank, you know, CSIS
is the big missile expert in DC. They
knew that this is what a war with Iran
would look like. In a lot of ways,
what's happening is kind of predictable.
That's kind of what it looks like on an
overall point of view now. And as you
said, the situation is incredibly fluid.
We don't know what's going to happen
tomorrow, let alone by next week.
>> Callum, what's your take on what's
happened so far?
>> Well, I mean, I think it's all a bit
concerning, honestly. I mean, I think
we're all uh we all remember the the uh
the second Iraq war and what happened
there. Obviously, if you change
anything, you remove the leadership,
then you don't really never really too
sure what the unintended consequences
might be. So, there's always that worry.
But there's two other things I think
about. One is that if you look at the
Ukraine Russia war, what Russia have
that the in a sense the West doesn't
have, they can they can be patient and
the Russians have always been able to be
patient in wars and wait people out, be
it waiting for winter or just waiting
for the will of the public to support a
project uh to to dissolve. And uh and I
think Iran probably have more patience.
I know the Americans are on like a
60-day timeline right now before it
needs congressional approval for some
sort of action and the Iranians can
probably outweight that. But the other
thing I think about I've read a bit
about the Iran Iraq war from the 1980s
and if you've read about that you
realize what Iran is capable of in terms
of of committing people to a cause. And
I think something that we don't
understand in the west is if you have a
regime that is deeply ideological and
committed and are willing to m people
for the cause then that's quite
difficult to overcome that that sense of
like almost morale in a sense even
though Iran is being crushed materially
there is an argument to be made that
they're being that the morale is being
crushed into a kind of a a hard diamond
of of resistance. And so I think that,
you know, the the real question is
whether the Americans have the stomach
for a protracted conflict.
>> Well, that's a good point because I
remember in the Iraq war 2003,
so many of us Americans had come to
believe that all the Iraqis were like
the exiles who were encouraging the war,
you know, that they were all going to
welcome us as liberators and turn into a
liberal democracy. Uh I think we're
seeing a replay of the same thing here
when uh a lot of us and anybody with a
heart has to feel sorry for what the
Iranian people have had to go through
under the regime of the mullis. At the
same time they've got a lot of support.
I want to turn to Raymond. Raymond,
you're a professional historian. Uh your
book the sword and the scimitar is a
history of the long conflict between
Islam, various armies of Islam and the
west. How do you read what's happening
now through a historical lens?
>> Yeah, good question. Um, and that's
exactly how I do see it. Kind of the
long view. And sort of going off what
Callum said is, um, I think we're
projecting a lot and we're and we're
we're falling back on the old paradigms,
old models of the Saddam Hussein and
Afghanistan and we think it's going to
be in, you know, in that exact order and
things are going to be simple. Not that
they were necessarily simple, but that
they'll follow those paradigms. I think
with Iran there's it's a little
different because it is a religious
organ. It's the largest actual Islamic
republic in the region and it's also
Shia and so based what K was saying for
example we've essentially made a martyr
of Kamani I mean that's it he's actually
now seen it's not that of course in the
west we can say he's an evil terrorist
etc but there it's actually galvanizing
people to a great extent
>> the supreme leader
>> supreme leader yeah and who apparently
knew that where he was was not safe and
he willingly stayed there so that even
kind of feeds into
But I also see it from the lens of uh
what very few people and policy makers
are aware of the idea of meism
because Iran is not just Muslim, it's
Shia Muslim and of course they have
their major differences and similarities
but what's notable is they really have a
strong esquetological component to their
world view.
>> They like end of the world
>> end end times kind of thing and there's
a Mahi figure. means a guided one and
it's a long story about who he is and
where he comes from and how he manifests
himself. He's actually supposed to be
one of the imams of the Shia who went
into what's called occultation and
disappeared for hidden the im.
>> Yes. And he's going to come back. Now,
one of the ways to bring him back is to
fight um Islam's greatest enemies which
from Iran's perspective it's named them
the two great Satans of course, Israel
and America. And so my point is that
this sort of theological worldview is
actually can in a way is working um with
Iran to against the US and Israel in a
in a possibly in a really bad way
because it's what I'm trying to say is
when you talk about nuclear powers right
the whole idea of nuclear power is that
is the balance theory right the balance
of power deterrence you have it I have
it no one's going to press the button
but when you have people who are
ideologically driven And the component
that is or the one group that is
especially indoctrinated in the idea of
meism is the um is the Islamic
revolutionary guard actually. Okay.
>> Yeah. C help us understand the conflict
within the Muslim world in the Middle
East. You mentioned that Iran is a Shia
power. the Gulf Arab states were Sunnis
and I've been going to the Middle East
for a while and all of the Gulf Arab
states were terrified of Iran, of the
Shia superpower. Um, how should we read
this conflict now that Iran is attacking
America's Sunni allies in the Gulf?
>> Well, it's a I mean, in that context,
it's just attacking the Sunni Arabs
because they are American allies. And in
that case, I guess it would be soft
targets, easy targets for Iran. But in
the greater picture of things between
the Sunnis and Shi and to give you just
a very succinct summary of how they come
about, it's actually it was about a
succession crisis that dealt after
Muhammad, Prophet Muhammad dies. So the
Sunnis were essentially the majority who
are 90% of the Muslim world who believed
in anyone could be a khalif or a
successor of Muhammad. Whereas the Shia
was the was the one small group that
believed he it had to be his blood and
generally would go through his daughter
Fatima and his first cousin Ali and
Ali's the first imam. Okay. And then
they go and the imam in in Shia the so
that's the thing the Sunnis don't have
the imam they have imams of course
prayer leaders but the imam in Shia
theology is like an immaculate
character. He's almost he's perfect and
people like the supreme leader and the
Ayatollah, they're seen as his kind of
representatives and voice while he's
hidden. So, it's the very mystical
aspect to it, but it also makes that
kind of mentality, that world view much
more prone to using nuclear weapons
because it's actually meant to usher in.
You can't bring the Mahi without
ushering in the end times by attacking
and ideally obliterating your enemies.
So that's why I was saying earlier the
balance of power theory doesn't work
very well when you think about a group
like that who thinks that way. But but
in so far as the Sunni and Shia thing
that's just been going on for centuries
and basically um America's allies are
the Sunnis which is also ironic. One
last point is because the Sunnis um who
are our great allies are actually much
more prone to being what we call radical
Muslims. Right?
>> So Islamic terrorists, ISIS, al-Qaeda,
you name it are Sunnis. Okay. So, that's
a little interesting.
>> You know, uh it's interesting you bring
up the religious angle here, which is
not something that most of our planners
in the west think about. I there was a
report on X that one American lower
level commander told his troops that
Donald Trump is leading us in a war that
will bring back Jesus Christ. And I
don't that is not a common view within
Christianity. that there's a subset of
Christians, usually those who are very
much allied with Israel, who believe
that and believe there is a religious
dimension here. This is why I was very
alarmed uh the other night right after
the war started when the Iranians
started sending missiles into Jerusalem.
They had one that struck right outside
the old city. It was half a mile from
the Dome of the Rock, which is on the
Temple Mount. Now among a certain number
of uh evangelical Christians in America,
they believe that the Jewish temple has
to be rebuilt on the temple mount in
order for Christ to return. And if that
missile were to have landed on the Dome
of the Rock, I mean that would set off
an electrifying effect, at least among
Americans and also among Israelis who
are more religious. But the thing that
worries me most about this right now
from a political point of view is Donald
Trump did not prepare the American
people for this. George W. Bush spent
over a year preparing the Americans
politically
for war with Iraq, which is uh was
always going to be a much easier thing
uh for America, even though it didn't
turn out to be easy at all. But Trump
ran into this war. Most people in
America are against this war according
to the polls and I think even among the
Republicans only about half of
Republicans support this war. Do you see
Philip political risk here for Donald
Trump and also for the leaders in
Europe?
>> So I think there's kind of a couple of
components to this. So the first of it
is exactly what you've just said. the
the public were not prepared for this
war. When America went into Iraq, it had
been it nearly two years since 911. I
mean, there was, you know,
>> 72% of the American people agreed with
the war when it was launched.
>> That's right. And people remembered
9/11. They were really shook up about
it. That's not the world we live in
today. And people haven't been prepared
for this war in America. So, that's one
aspect of it. The other aspect of it is
increasingly I see signs that this war
is becoming partisan actually in America
much quicker than the Iraq war did. That
took a while took a protest movement to
grow up and it only really became
establishment when Barack Obama got
elected the first time. Today, this
morning the New York Times is publishing
photographs of American bases that have
been severely damaged. Now, I don't want
to sound like a crazy conspiracy not,
but generally in warfare, you suppress
those photos. You don't show them to the
public. It's an American base and
there's been a lot of damage.
>> So, the media aren't playing along.
>> The media aren't playing along with
this. And if they're getting leaks of
those photographs, people in the
Pentagon aren't playing along because I
don't think they're I don't think a lot
of people in the establishment are in
favor of this war. And that brings to
the third point. This war is far more
risky from the point of view of win-
lose than Iraq for some of the reasons
that Raymond's just said. It's a Shiite
country and the IRGC as you say are holy
warriors in a sense. I mean that's how
they view themselves. The current
situation in Iran is that the the powers
being delegated. They have they have a
defense compact as it were that they
call mosaic defense doctrine. And what
they do is they they distribute command
and control to 30 regional IRGC
commanders. Those commanders have some
sort of vague tasks. Destroy Dubai.
Attack Israel. This guy, this guy.
They're pretty much allowed to do what
they see fit there. Those guys make the
strike decisions. To the extent that
there is civilian leadership, it will
probably be the new Ayatollah.
>> The son of the supreme leader.
>> The son of the supreme leader. Now
Ayatollah Kam2 has had his whole family
killed. His wife was killed, his child
was killed, and his parents were killed.
So you have no one to negotiate with.
You have a dispersed regional command
structure that allows independent IRGC
commanders who, if they are killed, have
three replacements underneath them who
will only get more angry as each one is
killed. You have that. They're all
sitting on top of giant missile bases
that are buried underground that you
can't air strike. Some of them have
holes cut out. They look like something
out of a Bond cartoon or something where
you can actually launch from underneath
mountains. Just as me talking about the
overall strategic picture is coming from
fairly mainstream sources like CSIS,
what I'm about to say also comes from
mainstream sources, America has very
limited missiles in the region. They
went in with 600 Tomahawks. I think
there's probably 150 left uh today.
>> And and they're not cheap missiles,
right? They're not cheap missiles, but
to even to to replace them, you have to
bring a ship to dock and you have to use
a crane to put them in. It takes a long
time. So to restock, to resupply is 2 to
4 weeks. So they have about 600 Tomahawk
missiles. As far as I can tell, they
have about 2500 to 3,000 interceptors,
Patriot and TAD interceptors in the
entire region. So what that means is
that once they run out of ammo, probably
interceptors are the main US,
>> then they have two choices. They can
either sit there and take hits or they
can go or they can leave. But if they
leave, the bases are still there and the
IRGC commanders who are now in control
of the military can continue striking
striking the base. In that case, they
can go and they can reload the ships and
they can reload the air defense
batteries to the best extent that they
can. That'll be very difficult. and then
they can come back for round two and
then we have the cycle repeat again. So
I just don't see an offramp to this. Who
who do you negotiate with? You can't
negotiate with the IRGC commanders. They
are just given a mission and they're
told to complete it as best they can. To
the extent that there is civilian
leadership, it's the new Ayatollah and
America, as far as he's concerned, just
killed his whole family. So who do you
negotiate with here? So the potential
here for a catastrophe and I mean a cat
catastrophic loss of some sort is so
much higher than in Iraq.
>> There's a couple things to say. One is I
agree with Philip and and uh one thing
is 6 weeks ago we saw this uh fermented
revolution counter revolution in a sense
in Iran and uh and Trump was saying we
support you but the truth is what ended
up happening is I think 20,000 people
were I think it was 20,000 killed 30,000
killed and and many imprisoned. It tends
to be throughout history, but whenever a
revolution happens, it's actually quite
a small number of people. It's the
hardcore of people who are really
willing, have the the means, the
courage, the just the moment to do
something. Those people came out then
and have either been killed or jailed.
And so there's a real question around
whether there is just in the street
people right now who form that hardcore
to uh incite some sort of movement to
take advantage of the conflict. Um, but
the second thing is, I mean, I think,
and Phil's been hinting at this, the way
we tend to think about war in our sort
of postw World War II era from the West,
we think of war as quite rational, about
combat rather than peer-to-peer war. You
know, the last peer-to-peer war was
probably the Korean War where it wasn't
simply one or two or three or four
deaths, but so many deaths you can't
bury them. You have to leave them
behind. And um, this is not a rational
war we're facing. This is something we
haven't potentially haven't seen for
quite a long time. Although if you're
Iraqi, you remember having a war exactly
like this with Iran in the 1980s. And I
think it's worth noting, and we've
hinted at this, that this war has a
religious component. Obviously, there's
a theocracy, but there's also a degree
of evangelism on the other side as well.
And so, these two things are are really
um uh they're two millinarian movements,
one of which is an apocalyptic
millinarian movement that ceases to be
rational. But there's something else
here. There is the irresistible force of
Trump's will behind American foreign
policy and you have the immovable object
of a theocracy that cannot collapse.
They cannot concede because if they
concede then they'll be out of power in
a week. So they they cannot concede. But
Trump, have you ever seen Trump ever
concede on anything? uh so you really
have this this extraordinary situation
now where both sides are locked into uh
a position where they cannot back off
which therefore ceases to be uh the
concept of rationality ceases to be
relevant. So I think that it becomes
something that's almost impossible to uh
to analyze I think beyond sort of uh the
emotions involved in in in existential
crisis
>> and and that means win or lose.
>> Well, it means win or lose. But the
question is what does win mean? Because
one of the challenges I think is that uh
my thinking about this is that we often
talk these days about World War II has
it started and so on. My sense has been
if World War II will happen or indeed
has already happened and it's worth
noting when World War II began they
weren't calling it World War II. It took
a few instances a few months before
people probably said oh is World War II.
No one said it was Poland or the
Russians invading Finland and so on. We
look back in retrospect and call it
World War II collectively. It's arguable
really that we've been in World War II
in a more protracted sense for a few
years, but because but depending on how
you define it, it seems to me if we are
into World War II, what that will be is
the point where the umbrella of American
presence and power throughout the world
uh is uh is no longer capable of
maintaining the veneer of peace. The
Americans have like 10 or 12 carrier
groups all around the world. But the
truth is despite having the world's
biggest military, they cannot be focused
on more than one more than one or two
spheres at any one time. And so you've
already got you've had Venezuela, you've
had Ukraine, you had Israel, Palestine,
but now this is much bigger. And
suddenly what seems to me is possible is
when American power is distracted, all
of the unfinished business of the 20th
century will reopen like poorly sutured
wounds. uh it could be India, Pakistan,
it could be Taiwan, China and World War
II really is all of the things bursting
out when that umbrella is retreated. And
one last thing I'd add to this is that
you know there is a kind of a an
uncomfortable parallel really with Biden
in some sense with what's happening now
because when Biden withdrew from
Afghanistan and personally I don't think
we ever should have been there but when
he withdrew what he revealed was the
illusion of American moral supremacy.
what it revealed. We didn't really care
about the girls education. At the end,
it was a cynical decision to leave very
quickly and the Taliban returned. It
seems to me that if that was um sort of
puncturing the moral illusion, what this
risks doing now is puncturing the
illusion of material supremacy that the
Americans actually not just have moral
supremacy, but real marshall material
supremacy because they're testing it in
reality. And that's a very dangerous
thing to do in a situation like this.
Most the wars for decades have not been
peer-on. they have been uh going into a
state that was basically already, you
know, you knock the door, the door is
already off the hinges, you just knock
it over. This is, I think, quite
different,
>> right?
>> Yeah. Um, one of the things that Callum
said that I've also been thinking about
is when you look at the two opposing
sides and who's got more to lose, and
it's just very clear Iran has everything
to lose, so they're not going to easily
capitulate. And I'm pretty sure it seems
that the Trump administration was really
banking on a kind of decapitation strike
that would work instantly. And um I
don't know if he wants this to be a
protracted war, especially since he's
told the American people repeatedly he's
not going to get us involved in wars,
etc., etc. So definitely it's already
started off unpopular and it has the
potential to really become catastrophic
catastrophic for him especially.
>> And now they're talking about well we
might have to put troops on the ground
there. That's exactly a red line
politically at least.
>> Yeah. He he just gambled. He was hoping
that you you know I'm going to kill this
guy. And one and one more thing about
him, you know, the guy the Kamani that
died, he's actually was kind of seen
almost as a moderate because I think he
issued a couple of fatwas against using
nuclear power as a weapon, whereas the
other guy, the son, um is actually he's
for it. Uh so it's it's almost like you
got rid of the one guy who was almost uh
you know the moderate in that camp and
now they've all going to be extra
radicalized and they already have
different uh you know more extreme views
as is and they have nothing left to
lose. What what else are they going to
lose? So they're just really going to
buckle in I think and dig deep and
whereas I don't know if the Americans
are ready for that sort of thing. Now,
Philip, you're a professional economist
and you've been writing a lot about the
global economic consequences of the
closing of the straight of Hormuz. Tell
us what we're facing, what we around the
whole globe are facing by that narrow
street through which all of the oil from
the Persian Gulf passes. I think
Americans especially, but Westerners
generally have massively misinterpreted
what the Iranians mean when they say
stuff like death to America in the
streets.
That has been popularized possibly for
propaganda reasons that they really mean
that they're going to develop a bunch of
nuclear weapons and fire them off the
United States from America. Maybe they
would have done that. I don't think they
would have, but okay, fine. Maybe they
would have. That's not what they're
talking about. When they say death to
America, they mean death to the American
Empire. They mean the same thing that
the Taliban were saying when they were
fighting the Soviets. The Taliban did
not want to fight the Soviets to destroy
Russia. They wanted to destroy what they
saw as the Soviet Empire. That is what
the Iranians mean when they say death to
America. And here's the thing. They have
a plan to do it because we think, oh
well, it's just another Middle Eastern
war. We'll just contain it to the
region. You know, even if it goes poorly
or whatever, if people are even planning
in that direction, I don't know. Then,
you know, it ends and we're embarrassed
and everything like that. That's not
what's going on here. The way that the
Iranians are going to try and collapse
the American Empire as they see it is
financial and economically. And they
know exactly how to do this. Um they're
doing two things and potentially three.
So the first plank of the economic
warfare strategy is to attack the
banking system via UAE and some of the
strikes in Cyprus that have already
begun could move in that direction too,
but UAE is more important. And then
there's the big kahuna which is the
closure of the straits of Hormuz and the
attacking of the energy infrastructure
which has already started. So closing
the straight of Hormuz cuts off 15 to
20% of global oil supplies. We have seen
that before not the closure of the
straight of Hormuz but we have seen an
oil embargo in 1973 by the Saudis uh in
in in response to the Arab-Israeli war
in that year. It sent oil prices
absolutely bonkers and it resulted in
oil shortages um all over the western
world cues cars queuing for um for for
>> inflation through the roof
>> inflation through the roof right so
that's basically what closing the
straight of hormones does and then the
longr run version of that is attacking
the energy infrastructure which they're
doing so in that case and this speaks to
the fact that they're going all in they
see a total war going on here so they're
going to do whatever attack the energy
infrastructure Even if you can open the
straight of Hormuz, there won't be
anything left to ship through it. It'll
take you, you know, a year to rebuild or
something like that. So then you'll get
inflation a lot, very severe inflation,
probably worse than what we saw after
the Russian invasion of Ukraine. And at
that point, interest rates start to
rise. And what the Iranians are hoping
that'll do, and it might do, is create a
massive financial crisis and a run on US
government debt and a collapse of the
American economy. A full collapse of the
American economy. This is their plan.
And I'm not I'm not speculating here.
You can read about it.
>> So it's interesting because you think of
the Middle East, of course, you have the
straits, but you also have those key
airports to go from Europe to Asia.
You've seen these maps of what's
happened to the flights right now. And
uh and obviously you've mentioned the
banking system. So you're saying that in
a sense in the international system
that's in the Americ's image, the actual
weak point I I almost coincidentally is
next to Iran.
>> I wouldn't say the weak point, but if
you think of the financial se sector,
you you have a few hubs, right? You have
you have Hong Kong, you have
increasingly China, you have Singapore,
you have London, you have New York to a
certain extent, you have maybe you know
Europe in a in a sense, maybe Frankfurt
or something like that. But the one in
the Middle East, the one that deals with
all the oil revenues and so on is in
Dubai. And what that does is it recycles
the dollars in the region earned from
oil sales back into things like US
Treasury bonds and so on. So the point
of the the financial system that's
currently in place sustains the enormous
debt load of the United States and
sustains the enormous current account
deficit that the United States runs.
It's a very fragile system all in. Now
it's not very fragile dayto-day because
everyone will go along with it. But if
you throw a real monkey wrench into
that, it could blow up and that's what
the Iranians are planning to do. It's
it's a quite a sophisticated economic
warfare plan. I mean, they clearly have
some economists working on it.
>> And Donald Trump had said that, well, U
the US Navy will keep the straight open.
But I think that's pie in the sky
because the Navy has to be right all the
time. All the IRGC has to do is sink one
tanker and Lloyds of London the which
guarantees the insurance on these
tankers. It will withdraw all insurance.
Right. And
>> well, Trump is now saying that they're
going to create an insurance fund. But
look, it is a fantasy to reopen the
straight. They couldn't reopen the Red
Sea in the face of Houthi attacks. Iran
is like Houthi times a thousand. The
Houthi were a little proxy army that
they are testing these weapons out. The
Iranians are trying to lure Donald Trump
into the straight of Hormuz. They have
speedboats with short-range
anti-shipping missiles in caves all
along the coastline of Hormuz. And the
moment the US Navy go in there, they're
going to sink it. That's their plan.
This is not a secret. You can read about
it in CSIS report. Is this not sorry to
just one quick thing is that this also
is all the more dangerous I think
because if it's possible for the
Americans to be lured in uh you've also
got I think a leadership model on both
sides at the moment where neither side
will ever concede anything and so you
have the real potential for chaotic
escalation it seems
>> clearly
>> one thing that we're all all pins and
needles worried about is the possibility
of Islamic sleeper cells in Europe and
the United States And uh and not only
the sleeper cells which as as of today
have not been activated if they're there
but I think our intelligence services
believe that they are there but we are
also seeing the greater Islamification
of Europe since we were last here around
this table. There's been a a hugely
symbolic bi-election in Corton and
Denton. That's Greater Manchester in the
UK. That was one by the Green Party. You
know, this this uh constituency has been
in the hands of Labor for I think a
hundred years or so. And now Labor was
completely destroyed by the Green Party,
which is an alliance of the progressive
far-left and Muslims.
What does that tell us about what's
happening in British politics and potent
and potentially in European politics?
This is your wheelhouse, Raymond.
>> Well, it's the it's a great demographic
change that's been happening
incrementally and it's coming home to
roost. And um what you just said
actually is it's ironic because a lot of
people are always questioning why does
you know the green and the red as they
call them or the red as in communist and
or leftist and green Islamic alliance.
And you see it often progressive
leftists and they're being supported by
Muslims. And you were wondering what on
earth is this? How does how do they the
two work? Well, the Muslims are just
being cynical and um you know they're
they're they're voting them in. I
mentioned this before. There's there's
so many examples especially in America
where areas become very heavy um Islamic
populations and the left is always
cheerleading them on and helping them
and promoting them and then once they
come into power in one in one instance
in Michigan some city the city council
became Muslim majority. Yeah. Well, no,
that one too. But this one's I think
Hamrank Hamrank in Michigan. And when
the city council became um Muslim
majority, the first thing they did,
first order of business was to cancel
gay pride. And everyone on the left who
had sp you know, yeah, were just shocked
and mortified. How could you do this? I
thought we were allies. So I think what
they don't understand, the left doesn't
get is the Muslims are using them
cynically, of course, but they don't in
any way, shape, or form share any of
their ideologies, okay? liberal
ideologies, but in general, what's
happening and now with this Iran
business and um the potential crisis
that will happen, which probably will
lead to more migrants uh flooding in and
this sort of and this, you know, feeling
that people have that it's now we're
obligated to take in more and more. It's
just amazing like I said because when
you zoom out and look at it the big
picture and uh because a lot of people
are very myopic and they just think in
the now they're very temporal minded and
they can look in their city let's say in
the UK and it's still what under 10%
Muslim so in their mind that's not a big
deal but it actually is a big deal when
you really understand how it's happening
progressively and I saw a Pew report
that said by 2050 Germany is set to be
about 20% Muslim and that's without any
more immigration just based on
demographic growth of what's already
there. So it's just amazing that you
know this the continent of Europe which
was essentially the the final historic
bastion of Christianity and you know
well the white race and now it's being
essentially um taken over uh both by the
Islamic religion and by peoples from uh
around the from the third world
essentially. Uh Matt Goodwin uh a
British uh pundit public intellectual
and a former guest last year on view
from uh the Danube stood as the reform
candidate in that constituency in
Greater Manchester. He lost but uh he
gave a quote after his loss. He said
quote we are losing our country. A
dangerous Muslim sectarianism has
emerged. We have only one general
election left to say Britain. What do
you think of that?
>> I I mean I think I do some work on
demography. So Britain have have had net
negative domestic population growth for
about 4 years now and the entire economy
kind of relies on immigrant labor
because there's no productivity growth.
So just from an economic perspective,
there's two sources of long-term
economic growth uh growth in the labor
force and grow growth in labor
productivity. So there's no productivity
growth in Britain because the economy is
completely shot and it's hollowed out.
Manufacturing's gone. It kind of rests
all around the city of London and so on.
So the only way to keep GDP growing is
to keep immigration coming in. And why
do you have to do that? I'm not going to
be the stereotypical economist here and
say GDP means everything it doesn't. But
Britain is also close to bankruptcy. The
the government's engaged in a massive
austerity program at the moment. Um debt
is too high. It's very hard to issue
debt at the moment. And so the Treasury
basically forces um my understanding is
the Treasury basically forces the home
office to allow in you know as many
migrants as as are needed to grow the
economy because if they don't the
country just goes bankrupt and they
can't afford the welfare state. So I
think the problems are actually deeper.
I'm not saying that therefore you should
have you know mass migration. I I don't
think so. It kind of destroys society in
my view. But the the the deep problem
here is basically that Britain hasn't
had above replacement fertility rates
since 1971. That's 50 years and it's
starting to catch up with the country.
It's got a very high tax rate already.
The Treasury sees no other no other real
alternative. Um and yes, they could dep
prioritize um GDP growth. ICE has
suggested some reforms that could do
that, but then you have the issue of
borrowing. So you'd have to
depprioritize GDP growth and then you'd
have to massively cut the size of the
state. So the problems are really deep
in Britain.
>> Callum, you're British. What does this
mean politically? Do you think that Matt
Goodwin is right? We're one general
election away from saving the country.
And if not, why not?
>> Well, I mean it a lot of it comes down
to what you mean by saving. I mean the
the but I think that one thing that the
big sort of theme running through the
last 15 years of British politics
actually really the last 25 years since
since new labor or 28 30 years now maybe
since new labor became when Labour
turned into new labor under Tony Lair is
what I term the sort of ideological
gentrification of the left where the
Labor Party uh existed was created to
represent working-class interests and
you know whatever else is true about the
UK is a very class stratified society
even to today and uh and what we've done
in that period is strip away uh the u
the foundations of all the working-class
communities. Uh one of the reasons and
one of the things that people don't
often talk about when they talk about
say the uh the grooming gangs or the
rape gangs uh they're often in sort of
northern post-industrial towns. Yes, of
course there has been there's a there's
a sort of a a cultural element to to
that. Yes, the police were looking the
other way because of political
correctness. The other thing is that
these communities were often where the
girls were coming from were often
devastated working-class communities
where uh there which used to be quite
close-knit and now no one is there.
There's no social structure anymore. So
these girls are very vulnerable. There's
not the neighbors looking out for each
other and um
>> family breakdown
>> a family breakdown which is part of
that. And I I went to school in Barrow
and Finesse, which is one of the towns
where this was happening in the north.
And uh it's uh it's very close to home.
But it's uh uh but I think what's
happened on the left is you've had it
taken over by sort of middle class
political professionals. I mean, even
Jeremy Corbyn, who's seen as a great man
of the left, grew up in an old rectory
and is I think university educated and
quite middle class, lives in Islington.
Um and uh all all of the left were like
this. And and it's in the same way you
have in a city you have gentrification
where the the the the working-class
population are pushed out because the
houses become so expensive. On the left
in Britain you've just had ideological
gentrification right across it. And um
and so one of the yeah I have to say
with the UK Britain is very proud of the
fact that we're not a prejudice country
in the sense that you know 100 years ago
people were prejudiced against people
from Papa New Guinea and you would never
in a in a in a in in Islington at a
dinner no one would ever say anything
prejudiced against someone from a
foreign nation anymore. But you know
what is still an acceptable prejudice in
UK is against the provinces and against
the working class. And what you will
hear Yeah. And so when Brexit happened,
people just thought it was a bunch of
ignorant racists uh causing this. It's
it was so um dismissive of actually the
majority of the country. So I think the
political crisis we have is and the
reason the Greens are getting elected
and and so on is that you've you've just
had the Labor Party abandon its uh its
sort of working-class constituency. And
actually the Greens to some extent is a
good example of the sort of ideological
gentrification where people go for that.
Um, so this is where reform, I think,
were would they didn't win in that. Uh,
but they're one of the last parties that
I think that are actually standing up
for the working-class interests.
>> Well, Raymond, let's go to France for a
second. Um, last month, a 23-year-old
young uh right-wing Catholic uh Kentan
Danc was murdered by a group of French
Antifa.
And this has caused shock waves
throughout uh French politics.
uh because the the Antifa group was
connected to La France insumeis which is
the far-left party and uh there have
been protest in favor of Kentan in
memory of Kentan and we have next year
the uh presidential election coming up
in France this is all gone to the
benefit of the Rasmbblau national the
former national front uh what do you see
when you look at France and the Islam
ization of politics and the Islam goisma
islamo leftist movement
>> I see everywhere um every everywhere is
headed to civil war to be honest with
you that's that's the only kind of uh
the culmination of what's going on
either that or one group acquiesces and
capitulates namely to give them whatever
you know parlance we're speaking of
American or Europe but you know cons
normal people I'll put it that way okay
the natives either they have to
capitulate or there's going to be
essentially a war Because again going
back to the numbers and the growing the
the the demographic population explosion
of Muslims and migrants and so forth,
what are you going to do when it's 50%.
I mean or 60%. Now you're an absolute
minority. If 10% is creating so much
havoc, what's going to happen when it's
30%. Which is very realistic and you
know not too far from the horizon. So I
think uh and we're already seeing this I
think in the UK there's this new party
um reform Britain I think and the and
the language coming out is very you know
it's it's in on the one hand it's
refreshing because it's kind of language
that is needed on the other hand it's
pretty militant um you know he's they're
not just talking about stopping
migration they're talking about um
reversing it which means we're actually
going to which but you know is that bad
no I think that is actually necessary
that's the point they're in but once
they get to that point. The other side's
not going to just give in either. So,
this is just going to become a massive
conflict literally of civil war.
>> One thing I've been talking about a lot
for the last year is the prospect of
civil war in Britain and in continental
Europe. David Betts, an analyst at the
King's College London War Studies
Department. He's been sounding the alarm
for a while now, saying that from what
we know from the academic study of civil
war, all of the conditions that give
rise to civil war have been met in
Western Europe and in the UK,
specifically with a large and aggressive
migrant population. Um, is there a way
to back away from this? Cuz I I'll tell
you, I've been traveling in France and
people will tell you behind the scenes,
people in a position to know. I'm
thinking of a retired five-star French
general who told me this last year. He
said civil war can't be stopped now. Do
you see any way out of it?
>> Well, I mean, I have a we've talked
about this before, but I I have a kind
of a slight resistance on elements of
this narrative about civil war because,
you know, classically understood, if you
look up any definition of civil war,
it's two sides fighting for control of
the state, like the American Civil War.
But the the challenge is that what we're
seeing say in the UK is you have like
the white working-class population
facing tensions perhaps with the Muslim
community in the absence of the state's
presence or or doing the states not
doing anything which is leading to
perhaps the potential for communal
violence which
>> that means by civil war.
>> Yeah. But I don't think they're the same
category because I don't think they're
fighting for control of the state is two
sides fighting in the absence of the
state's presence.
>> It's like Northern Ireland.
>> Well,
this is just arguing over terminology. I
don't think it is though because I I
think it's civil war is a that there's a
the concept of again civil war is two
you know armies essentially fighting
over control of the state the English
civil war or the American civil war and
I just think the these categories do
matter it's not simply an academic
exercise because I think the the phrase
civil war is so loaded I do think there
is risk of communal violence if we don't
get community relations improved but the
concept of civil war I'm not sure what
the two sides are fighting for the state
put that aside and again this is Bett
said it would be more like Beirut and
Northern Ireland but uh if it comes to
that I mean it what's the offramp here
is there now an offramp or you know to
use uh Victor Orban's analogy in
something he recently said about you
know a metaphor about fish soup which is
to say you can't put toothpaste back
into the tube that's how we say in
English is there any way to avoid this
now or is this just locked in
>> I think it's locked And and it's uh like
I said, either either it happens or one
side has to acquies and essentially lose
its rights uh to the other side. And I
don't see the migrants or the leftists
doing that at all. Um I see
>> we're already seeing the quote unquote
solution to it in Britain. And it's
what's going to spread all over Western
Europe. We're going to have enormous
police states. I think what's happening
now is Britain is starting to prepare
for for something more dramatic in a
sense. You see it there because why
wouldn't you? I mean the state will have
an excuse to expand its power. It loves
expanding its power and the new
technologies that we're bringing in here
mean that you can expand the power much
more than you can say after the passing
of the Patriot Act. After
>> is going to be
>> AI is going to be huge and you know
taking human interaction out of the
picture. We saw some of this during co I
mean that seems to me like a model for a
kind of perfect police state in a way.
So I think Western Europe will respond
with a policing. That's how the state
always responds. people in Britain won't
talk about this. I don't understand why,
but these are so obviously outgrowths of
the troubles in Northern Ireland.
>> Um, and that's why Britain got a kind of
a a start a start on the way, but
that'll go that'll spread across Western
Europe. I think
>> we have to talk about the Hungarian
elections before we go because we're
running out of time. We're about five or
six weeks away from the election, April
12th. Um, it's hard to know what to make
of the polls. The polls are showing that
Victor Orban's challenger, Peter Majar
from the TISA party is far ahead. But I
remember I was here in 2022 for the
election. The polls were wildly wrong.
Um, feed us one and a virtual landslide.
So, where do we stand on the election
now 5 6 weeks out? And what are the
factors playing into the dynamics?
because I don't know about you guys, but
I'm hearing from Americans all the time
asking me who's going to win. Is Orban
going to win?
>> So, I noticed that the polls were off um
last year, about this time last year, I
realized that there was something very
strange going on in the polls, much
stranger than in 2022. All the polls
were kind of off in 2022, although the
government aligned ones were less. So,
this time around, what you've seen is
that the polls diverged. The polls are
now giving completely different
readings. So the ones affiliated with
the opposition are giving sometimes
crazy readings like a 20 point lead to
the TISA opposition party and the
government polls are showing a pretty
consistent plus 4% lead for Fidz. So the
polls have completely split. Now that
means one thing one set of polls is
fake. So the only question is are the
government aligned polls fake or are the
opposition polls fake? And so I ran some
tests last month using econometric
studies and I found that the variability
in the opposition polls was very high.
So I strongly suspect that the
opposition polls are are fake. And so
why would they be faking that? Well,
they did this in Georgia for example.
It's to discredit the results after the
election and say the election was
fraudulent.
>> Right. So, Kum, do you think that um if
Warban should win, the EU is going to be
extremely upset because they're throwing
everything they have at him? Do you
think that there could be real trouble,
you know, in the way that that Philip is
talking about?
>> Well, I mean, I certainly think that the
EU will be very unhappy if uh if he lost
because he's been uh
>> Peter Majar loses.
>> Yeah. if Peter Mario loses because
obviously you know Orban has been uh
from the EU's perspective very
inconvenient uh for them over the years
because he's been standing up for his
own country's interests and and his own
interpretation of how things should be
which doesn't align with the sort of
technocratic consensus you see in
Brussels. So I think obviously he's
going to you know he's been facing
headwinds on this since he came into
office as far as I can see and uh since
2010. I think it's only going to get it
seems to get more intense every cycle.
I've only been here 5 years, but I
wouldn't be surprised if it gets more
intense. Um, yeah, I mean, it's it's uh
but you know, I the main person I've
actually been reading on the the
election polling has actually been
Philillip. And uh so I haven't really
got much to say outside of that because
it's just uh it's it's it's very hard to
tell because it's so the polls are so
different. There's so much different
information. Well, talk about Philip,
help our our listeners understand what's
going on with the Jurishba pipeline and
why that has become such an important
election issue in Hungary.
>> Yeah. And since the start of the Iran
war, it's become even more so. Um, so
basically the uh decent portion of the
Hungarian oil supply is coming from the
Duchba pipeline
>> through Ukraine. through Ukraine from
Russia. But the fact that it wasn't shut
down at the beginning of the war,
there's a reason for it, right? The the
war was managed in at least a
semi-rational way, I'd say. And so
everybody secured their own energy
supply. And the DURA pipeline was
absolutely key to the Hungarian energy
supply
>> and Slovakia too.
>> And Slovakia and the region really
because if the Hungarian and Slovakian
oil supply dwindles, they'll start
buying from the region. So it's
important for Austria and other
countries as well. And what's been
happening in recent weeks is that the
Ukrainians have been weaponizing the DJA
pipeline first by preventing oil from
flowing through it. And then there was
an attack on it where it was in Russian
territory. It was a pumping station out
in near Tartan. But it was an attack. It
was aimed at the Drewba pipeline. It was
an act of violence against energy
infrastructure that the country relies
on. The real issue politically, now that
is a political issue in and of itself,
but Maguar won't say anything about it.
And this morning the prime minister's
office is saying that they have um
evidence that the the Ukrainians are
financing the Teisa campaign. So there's
and of course the TISA campaign also uh
used the Ukrainians to build their app
and harvested a bunch of Hungarians
data. So these these links between the
Ukrainians and the opposition and the
fact that the Ukrainians are using
violence to try and interfere in the
election is I mean it's completely
against European norms. It's very
concerning.
>> And it's also the case that uh Hungary
and Slovakia have been using their veto
uh within the EU to to hold up like I
it's a 90 billion euro uh transfer of
euro fund European funds to Ukraine and
how do you think that the Iran war if
that if that chokes off a lot of uh
Europe's oil supply will it force
Brussels to change its mind on the war?
They've already made a statement
yesterday. The Financial Times said that
the EU is now open to reopening uh
Russian oil supply.
>> Wow.
>> Yes. Yesterday they're desperate. They
had a big meeting and so now Victor
Orban is going to get to do a victory
lap and say, "I told you so. I told you
not to mess with energy security." The
entire premiership has been I told you
so.
>> The opposition the opposition will now
say that the Iran war was launched so
that so Victor Orban could do a victory
lap. No day.
>> So, uh, let's go to the final question.
Outside of immigration, which is the big
one, outside of immigration, what else
is now fish soup? Or to put it another
way, what else is the toothpaste that
has come out of the tube that has
dramatically affected society, but uh,
we can't get it back in. I I can start
by saying uh the introduction of the
smartphone in 2007 that was really a red
line because what it did was it gave the
internet to everybody all the time. Now
we have an entire generation of young
people who are accustomed to being
online all the time and this is having
dramatic social effects and even
neurological effects. There was a survey
that came out last year showing dramatic
uh fall off of literacy among the young
and mathematical literacy too and it's
almost entirely I believe because young
people are at a time when their brains
were developing they were constantly
online and neurological studies have
shown that it uh that heavy online use
affects the parts of the brain the
development of the parts of the brain
that make it uh possible to sustain
attention and memory. So uh I think that
future historians will look back to 2007
and the introduction of the smartphone
as a a Rubicon for not just for Western
civilization but for humanity. Right.
>> Yeah, I agree especially with what
you're saying, but in general with
technology in general, how it's sort of
taken over and being so intrusive as you
say. And the thing with it with
technology as we all know is it's a
double-edged sword. I mean, we all love
it. It helps us do our kinds of work
remotely and whatnot. But then the way
it's become so intrusive, especially
with younger people who haven't had a
chance to even develop their brains, and
this becomes their sort of epistemology,
walking around with the phone. Um, but
to me, I or toothpaste
>> to me it would be a little more abstract
and more philosophical. It would
actually be the thing that connects
everything. You you mentioned how
migration is the big one but what else?
And it's just uh it's it has different
names. You know they call the left
leftist thinking wokus I think which all
of this of course when it's all
condensed is a philosophical worldview
that has essentially it's almost like a
virus that has taken over especially
western type people and it's become you
know it's what degrades them and breaks
them down and makes them susceptible to
all sorts of things. If you look at
again the mig
>> what's that what is that philosophy
>> but if you look at the migrant uh crisis
for example that's all self-made as one
example it's a it's a self-made problem
that's why Hungary uh Victor Orban can
you know be this nation that's not as
powerful as Western Europe or the UK or
France and it doesn't have this issue
because he simply put up a fence which
they could have done but because of this
mind virus so well like I said it has
different names uh you know they call it
the left
>> well I mean what' you call Well,
globalism, uh, uni, humanitarian,
universalism.
>> No, no. I'm thinking more of the an act
leftism. Okay. Uh, the leftist
mentality. I don't want to use the word
liberal because liberal is good, but
extreme liberalism, wokeism, all of this
has just short changed the way people
thinking
that back
>> and uh, yeah. So, so I think that's the
big genie that out of the bottle that
needs to be, you know, be brought back
in to use your my version of your
analogy,
>> Callum. Well, I mean, my sense is that
that everything's now fish soup. I mean,
we we we've all just been helpful.
>> No, no, but I'm going somewhere. It's
like, you know,
>> everything's fish soup. Nothing's fish.
>> Well, my point is there's no fish left.
I mean, everything is just there.
There's just completely gone. And the
that we've all just been blended into
this into this world. What I mean by
everything's gone is that, you know,
what has gone is is stillness, silence,
and actually the the art of being
solitary. Uh now we hear a lot about
loneliness but there's a great I think
it's a quote from Robin Williams and he
said I used to think the worst thing was
being alone. Actually the worst thing is
being around people who make you feel
alone. We are all now constantly
connected to everyone but it's a very
lonely space being constantly online.
But actually the art of actually
paradoxical
>> very paradoxical. Yeah. But I find that
but the art of being solitary not not
lonely but solitary of being being kind
of not having constant stimulation to
distract you having to sit with yourself
that has completely fallen out the
culture now uh for whole generations
when I even find it myself that if I
have a moment of boredom I can pull my
phone out and and check the news and see
which war has started and check one of
Philips's polling analyses or whatever
it is I'm never just left alone to think
in in a long form way and that's for our
generation for for the kids coming
through now, they've never even
experienced it. I at least remember the
'9s when I'd spend long summers as a kid
wondering what to do and I'd be creative
to fill that space. Um I I haven't had
that sort of space for years and I think
the whole culture is militating against
uh being solitary and sings any value in
that.
>> I think was it Pascal who said that so
many of the problems of the world are
caused by the inability of man to sit
quietly in his room.
>> Exactly. It's exactly that.
>> Phillip, you get the last word. Well,
I'd say the war, but we've talked about
that enough. I do think this war is
going to completely change the world. I
think we've been in the process of that
change for about 5 years, transition to
the multipolar world and so on. But I
think that's a huge discussion. But I
think the the AI discussion, I found it
extremely frustrating in a lot of ways
because it's often undertaken in a kind
of metaphysical dimension. I think the
real impact of AI is that it could
render very large portions of the
population illiterate. That's actually
my real concern. I fear that that the
part of the population that doesn't make
an active uh attempt to learn how to not
just read but probably write at this
point will be rendered illiterate
functionally illiterate. I think this is
actually going to happen. I happen
>> it's happening already and and what
that'll do is it'll mean our culture or
at least the mass culture will revert to
oral culture which as we know being
educated people is a very quite a
primitive form of culture. So um I do
fear that that is actually in the
process of happening now. We're going to
get mass amounts of the population
functionally illiterate. even people who
we would consider today to be educated
and they'll at first pretend to be
literate by using the AI to produce you
know literary products or you know just
basic things and then over time it'll
become normalized and over time you'll
just go well yeah of course I mean
everybody's using the AI because I don't
think it's actually going to eliminate
the writing and the creative thinking I
think it'll just create this enormous
class divide between the people who put
the effort into writing and the people
who are in the kind of oral culture.
>> I think this is happening now.
>> The future could be then politically a
sort of feudal society where those who
know how to use their brains and who
have not had their brains whacked on AI
are able to rule over the great mass of
people who are functionally illiterate.
>> Well, we're already there.
>> Or the literate will be a persecuted
minority. It's one of the two.
>> That's possible. Um, who me? Reed? No.
Uh, it's like Paul Pot, you know, when
when Paul Pot took over Cambodia, they
shot anybody with glasses thinking they
were intellectuals. Yeah.
>> On that happy note, gentlemen, thank you
for joining us today. Philip Pilington,
Callum Nicholson, Raymond Ibrahim, and
I'm Rod Dreer. Thank you for being with
us on View from the Danube. Bring back
the fight.
Bring back the flame.
Bring back the fire and the rightous
name.